PROFESSOR: We have a lot of
fun material to cover today,
so let's get started.
We start with a few basic
questions about-- well,
first is a topology question.
What is a handle?
In general, a handle is really
a transformation on a surface.
I thought I will demonstrate in
the context of glass blowing.
So this is what it looks
like if you're making a cup.
You take some hot glass.
You attach it to your surface.
You cut it off your hot pipe.
And then you bring it around
and attach it to another point,
and so that's a handle.
You've probably used
handles before in real life.
In general, or in the
mathematical setting,
it's the same thing
but on a 2D surface.
So imagine you have
some 2D surface.
You take two disk-like
regions on the surface
and then you attach on a
handle-- something like that.
So it's an operation
you can do to a surface.
And you can keep adding handles.
I don't think there's
a clear way to say,
oh, this is clearly a handle,
except to have added it
as a handle.
In general, the nice theorem
for two dimensional surfaces--
so here's a coffee cup being
converted into a torus,
because it has
genus 1, meaning it
has essentially
one handle in it.
In general, you take
any orientable surface
without boundary-- this is
locally two dimensional-- then
it will be a sphere plus some
non-negative number of handles.
And that's a
classification theorem
for orientable surfaces.
It's only slightly
more complicated
for non-orientable surfaces.
And then 3D surfaces
are even harder
and was only recently solved.
But this is two
dimensional surfaces,
which is easy and clean.
There is a way to compute
genus and in some sense
learn how many
handles are there.
But there isn't a unique
thing of, oh, this part
is clearly a handle.
But when you draw it
this way, it kind of
becomes clear this is a handle.
This is a handle.
But there isn't a
formal sense in which--
I don't know-- this thing is not
a handle or some weird thing.
I think that's
all about handles.
Hopefully that answers things.
Of course, things
get more complicated
when you have a boundary,
which we usually call holes.
But the next question is
about holes in the unfoldings.
So I claim that convex
polyhedron, when
you unfold them, never have
holes in the unfolded form.
And this is to contrast this
example, which is not convex.
But you can unfold it by
cutting these two edges.
And you've got a little hole.
So I showed this in lecture.
And natural question
is, why isn't this
possible for convex polyhedron?
So I thought I would prove that.
And the proof uses a cool
theorem, which we'll probably
be seeing again, called
the Gauss-Bonnet theorem.
And it says that if you
have some surface, which
is homeomorphic to a
sphere-- so I don't
want any handles
for this theorem.
And of course, convex
polyhedra our sphere-like.
They don't have handles.
And I take a-- let me
take a better color--
I take a closed curve
non-self-intersecting closed
curve on that
surface-- that defines
an interior and an exterior.
Then what the
Gauss-Bonnet theorem
says is that if you look
at the curvature that's
enclosed by the curve-- the
total curvature by this closed
curve on the surface-- and
you add on the total turn
angle along the curve-- so here,
the curve is turning right.
Here, it's turning
left, right, left.
Left is positive.
Right is negative.
Then these always add
up to 360 degrees.
We're not going to
prove this theorem,
but we're going to use it.
So this is a nice invariant
for sphere-like things.
When you have handles,
this number changes.
I think it's 0 for a torus.
Well, I won't try to guess
it, because it's a little bit
subtle to get right.
One fun consequence of this--
let's just get warmed up--
suppose you take a
sphere like object
and you take a
closed curve-- this
is going to be pretty
abstract-- in this direction,
then it says, OK, the
total amount of curvature
in here plus the total
turn angle equals 360.
Now suppose that I
turn the curve around.
So I just reverse the
direction-- like this.
And so now, the interior
is this stuff out here.
And then we get that the total
curvature outside the curve,
plus the total turn angle of
the blue thing, equals 360.
If I add those two
equations together,
the total turn angle cancels.
Because wherever red turns,
left blue turns right.
And so this term disappears.
And so what we get is
that the total curvature
inside the curve, plus the total
curvature outside the curve,
equals 720.
So this is a nice
topological invariant
of sphere-like polyhedra.
You add up the total
curvature everywhere--
it didn't really matter what the
curve was-- you always get 720.
And so this is kind of neat.
For convex polyhedra,
this means you
have to somehow divvy
up this curvature.
Because all curvatures
are positive.
So 720 is, somehow,
spread around.
But you have to have
exactly that much.
For non-convex things, you could
have some negative curvature
that balances out a lot
of positive curvature.
So you can have a lot of both.
But you have almost the
same amount of each.
Just you have
exactly 720 excess.
that's just a fun fact.
We'll be using that in
the future, I think.
OK, that was Gauss-Bonnet.
Now let's use it
to prove that this
can't happen for
convex polyhedron.
So the idea is, suppose you have
an unfolding with a hole in it.
So this is the surface out here.
Then I'm going to take
a closed curve that
walks around the hole but
stays inside the unfolding.
And then, of course, I'm
visualizing that really
on the polyhedron.
So I want the
interior of the curve
to enclose the hole-- or
what becomes the hole.
Now, what we learned
from Gauss-Bonnet
is that the curvature
enclosed by this thing,
plus the total turn angle
of the curve, equals 360.
The total turn angle
of the curve is 360.
It's a planar walk here.
So turn angle-- total
turn here is 360 degrees.
Now, if we have a
convex polyhedron,
then this curvature
has to be non-negative.
Well, I mean, sorry.
In any case here, this
curvature better equal 0.
For convex polyhedra, this is
a sum of vertex curvatures.
For convex polyhedra,
every vertex
has strictly positive
curvature actually.
I mean the zero curvature
vertices aren't vertices.
They're just points
on the surface.
So for convex
polyhedron, if you're
going to have zero
total curvature,
that means you actually
have no curvature.
So you have no vertices
enclosed in here,
which is a contradiction.
That means there wasn't
a hole to open up.
Technically, you could
do something weird
like-- I don't know,
let's take a cube.
You could say, OK, I'm going
to make a couple cuts here
that do nothing.
This is kind of a
weird situation.
We're going to add those cuts.
And then, of course, you could
draw this curve around it
and say, oh yeah, look.
I've got lots of zero
curvature vertices inside here.
In general, whenever you
have zero curvature vertices,
you could always just suture
them back up-- uncut them--
and there'd be no
difference in the unfolding.
So you have to assume
that you've already
removed pointless cuts.
Then there'll be no
vertices in there.
And so then, in fact, there was
no hole for convex polyhedra.
For non-convex polyhedra, you
can have a negative curvature
vertex that balances out some
positive curvature vertices.
And so the total curvature
here equals zero.
But you have three vertices.
And that just can't
happen for convex.
Next quick question
is, when we're
talking about the cut
locus and the ridge tree,
we drew some pictures.
The claim is that it
was a spanning tree
of the polyhedron.
And in particular, the
leaves of the tree--
the degree 1
vertices-- are exactly
the vertices of the polyhedron.
And I hadn't actually
realized this,
but in fact, it's not
really literally true.
It's kind of spiritually true.
The vertices, in fact, have
unique shortest paths to x.
So remember, we have some
point, x, on the surface.
And we're looking at
points, like this one,
they have non-unique
shortest paths to x.
This is, if you grow
the fire around x,
where does the fire meet itself.
And it will meet
itself along this edge,
because you could
go around this way
or go around this way and
it's equal length path.
But at the vertex,
there's actually
a unique way to go there.
That's the black line.
So technically, this point
is not on the ridge tree.
But all of these points are.
So this is kind of
like a limiting point
of the ridge tree points.
So we think of it as
being on the ridge tree.
I mean, you could think
of as cut are not cut.
It doesn't really matter.
But you cut right next to it,
so effectively the same thing.
But it is a neat
point-- a subtle point--
that these guys have
unique shortest paths.
Whereas, these do not.
Still we cut all the
way up to corner.
All right, that is that.
So now we have a bunch of
newer and more exciting
things-- or updates that
you haven't heard of.
One question that we mentioned
was generalizing the star
and source unfoldings.
And there's a new
paper about this.
This is with my PhD
advisor, Anna Lubiw,
and this is just a
warm up to get started.
So here, we have a box,
if we take a point x.
And let's see, here we have
the source unfolding from x.
And here, we have the star
unfolding, just for comparison.
It's also kind of fun to
see them side by side.
They're color coded.
So where you cut is the
ridge tree, in this case.
And you end up gluing
along the ridge tree
in the star unfolding.
Now, we're going to
generalize things
a little bit in that we're
going to generalize the source
unfolding, specifically.
So source unfolding,
you have a point x.
And you just sort of
shoot shortest paths all
from x, and that's
what you keep.
And you end up cutting
along the ridge tree, which
is the void in our
diagram at this point.
So I'm going to generalize
that a little bit
and think of this as
a tiny little circle.
And in general,
what I'm going to do
is the source unfolding
outside the circle.
And so when the circle is really
tiny, it is just the source
unfolding.
But in general, I'm going
to do the star unfolding
inside the circle.
OK.
So in this case,
nothing changes.
But next example is
going to be more general.
Instead of being a
single point here,
I'm going to take
a geodesic arc--
a straight line on the surface.
So here's an example of that.
We have a square-based pyramid.
We drew a straight
line on the surface.
If you unfolded it,
it would be straight.
We're thinking of
having a little--
I think it's called a racetrack
curve in mathematics--
around that straight line.
And I'm going to do star
unfolding on the inside.
In this case, there's no
vertices on the inside,
so nothing happens.
And then we do source
unfolding on the outside.
This is actually
previously known
to unfold by
O'Rourke and others.
But we have a simpler
proof, essentially.
And we're going to
generalize it more.
But what we do is the source
unfolding on the outside.
So you take shortest
paths-- from every point,
you take its shortest
path to this geodesic.
That's, some of these blue lines
show various shortest paths.
That's what you keep.
The ridge tree is if you
light fire simultaneously
along this entire segment,
where does it burn out?
And that's the purple stuff.
And this is the
complementary diagram,
where you do the reverse, which
would be the star unfolding
on the outside, source
unfolding on the inside.
So you glue along
the purple stuff
instead of cutting
along the purple stuff.
And this, we conjecture, doesn't
overlap but we don't know.
All right, so fine.
That looks easy.
And you can prove that
this doesn't overlap.
Before you proved
it, because you just
had shortest paths emanating
in all directions around x.
Now, you have shortest
paths emanating
in 180 degrees of directions
around this endpoint.
Then they are all just straight.
And then they rotate
around 180 degrees here.
And then they're
all just straight.
And so there can't be
anything overlapping,
because you're just
taking a continuum
of these segments
of varying lengths.
They don't overlap.
Here, they're all parallel.
Here, they sweep nicely.
In general, if they
always turn clockwise
as you walk along the
curve, you're fine.
OK, here's a more general one.
In general, what we can
prove is that if you
have a convex curve
on the surface--
so it always turns to the
left, I think technically.
The angle on the left
hand side is always
less than or equal
to 180 degrees.
You have to be a
little careful what
it means to turn to the left.
When you hit a vertex, you've
got less than 360 total.
So what does to the left mean?
It just means you've got less
than 180 degrees of material
on your left side.
So this is an example
of a convex curve.
It's got some circular arcs.
We're no longer
tracking along some--
we're no longer just
doubling along some curve.
Here, we enclose a
vertex, which makes
it a little more exciting,
because now what we're
going to do star unfolding
on the inside, which remember
was cutting along shortest
paths from every vertex
to your thing.
In this case, your thing
is no longer a point, x.
It is now this convex curve.
So let's say this is
the shortest path here.
It might be than one choice, but
we're going to-- actually, no.
This is the shortest path.
This is a root 2 diagonal.
This is length 1.
So we're going to
come along here
and that's this dashed line.
So it got opened
up here, because we
had too little material here.
We open it up.
But otherwise, it acts the same.
In particular, outside
this red curve,
it's just source unfolding.
You've got all these
shortest paths.
And again, what we argue--
and I'm not going to prove
it here-- is that all
of these shortest paths
keep turning clockwise and
do so exactly 360 degrees.
There's some jumps when
you hit these gaps.
And you have to kind
of jump over them.
But still, you
have no collision.
And drawn over here
is the reverse,
where we would star unfold the
outside of a convex curve--
because it's a convex curve,
the inside and outside
are different-- and source
unfold on the inside.
And this, we conjecture,
doesn't overlap.
But we don't know
how to prove it.
This thing is a generalization
of the source unfolding.
Because when this curve is super
tiny, it is a source unfolding.
This thing would
be a generalization
of the star unfolding, but
we don't know whether works.
I think one more example here.
This is a way to
generate convex curves.
You start from some point, x.
And you design it-- you
choose a direction so
that if you go straight--
so this curve goes straight
everywhere except x.
If you set it up right,
you come back to x.
So this, in particular,
is a convex curve,
because it's straight
everywhere except x.
And at x, it's convex.
And so, in this case, we
enclose a few vertices.
On the inside, we've
got V3, V7, V6.
So each of those ends up getting
cut here in these green lines.
And so, like this one
is a very tiny cut.
We just cut there at V3.
The other ones
are little bigger.
But they open up.
And yeah, I guess,
this is the-- well,
it's a few different
versions of the picture here.
But again, you look
at the shortest paths.
Here, they're all parallel.
Here, they sweep.
Here, we jump, but
it's just the same
as sweeping-- it
doesn't hurt you.
Then they're all parallel.
Then we jump.
Then they're all parallel,
in this particular example.
But they will always
proceed clockwise
around the curve, which
here is drawn red.
Gets split up a
little bit, but you
can show because
of that sweeping,
they won't hit each other.
And you have
non-overlapping unfolding.
So we call this sun
unfolding, because of the rays
that sweep around.
And because we have
a convex curve,
it's kind of like the sun.
So that's a new unfolding.
The obvious open
question is the reverse,
when you glue around
the purple sides
instead of the--
It's essentially,
instead of having
a convex curve,
you have a reflex curve,
exactly the opposite.
What happens, we don't know.
It's a lot harder to prove.
Because in particular,
it's a lot harder
to prove that the star
unfolding doesn't overlap.
And you've got to include
at least that proof
in any generalization of it.
Next topic of unfolding
kind of related
we call zipper unfolding.
So these are some examples of
real felt models with a zipper.
The goal is, I want an unfolding
that has a single zipper.
And you just pull the zipper,
and it makes your polyhedron.
So this is an example
of an octahedron.
This one is actually
not even a polyhedron.
It has two pyramidal
pockets in it.
And it's actually closed
off in the middle.
I think we have a
little video here
of what it looks like
to open that octahedron.
So what does it take
to have a single zipper
line, that connects
everything together?
Well, if you think
about it, that
means that the cuts that you
make must follow a single path.
So in general, the cuts form
a tree on a convex polyhedron.
We want that tree
to be just a path.
So it's like a Hamiltonian path.
It's got to visit all the
vertices in some order.
And you'd like it to
unfold without overlap.
So is this always possible?
This is a father, son,
mother, son, son paper.
So this is my advisor
again and her two sons.
Although we like to say this
a paper with her three sons,
because I'm her academic
son-- or four, if you count
Marty too.
She was his advisor as well.
So here are some examples
of good unfolding.
So we have the platonic solids.
These are just
typical unfoldings.
These are all zipper unfoldings.
So we're cutting along edges,
along a Hamiltonian path
that doesn't overlap.
They all have this kind
of nice snake like shape.
And so all platonic
solids can be
made by zipper edge unfoldings.
Next, we did Archimedean solids.
This is a lot more work.
But again, you get these
nice S-like curves.
And they're all
zipper unfolding,
because they're all
possible and they'll
have these Hamiltonian paths,
cuts, and avoid overlap.
But you may notice,
there's one missing up
there-- the great
Rhombi-Cosi-Dodecahedron,
my favorite Archimedean solid.
And it has a rather
different looking unfolding.
As far as we can tell,
there's no S-shaped one--
whatever that means.
But you have to have a tree.
These examples all
had path-like--
The dual graph was
roughly a path.
I guess it branches
a little bit here.
Here, it's very
tree like, I guess.
So all Archimedean
solids can be done.
One open question,
next category up,
is Johnson solids, which
are all polyhedron made
with regular polygon faces--
convex polyhedron made
by regular polygonal faces.
Those we don't know,
whether they always
have zipper unfoldings.
But we do know there are
some convex polyhedra--
like this rhombic dodecahedron--
that do not have zipper
unfoldings if you
only cut along edges.
Because this graph has
no Hamiltonian path.
So never mind avoiding overlap.
There's some polyhedra that
just aren't Hamiltonian.
There's no path it visits
every vertex exactly
once and only follows edges.
So there's nothing
you could even
hope to cut along
and avoid overlap.
So that's bad news
for edge unfoldings.
The big open question here
is for general unfoldings
if you're allowed to cut
anywhere on a convex surface
and do things like
the sun unfolding.
I mean, edge
unfoldings, we don't
know how to do them anyway.
So if you allow
general unfoldings,
we've got star unfolding,
source unfolding, sun unfolding,
all sorts of things.
But none of them are
zipper unfoldings.
They all cut along trees.
Like star unfolding
cuts along a star.
The source unfolding cuts
along the ridge tree,
which is going to be
very tree like thing.
Can you always convert a
tree cut into a path cut?
We've tried.
It seems quite challenging.
So that's the open problem.
Does every convex polyhedron
have a general zipper
unfolding, because edge
unfolding is always too much
to hope for.
So those are some fun
problems to think about.
It's kind of like
zipper unfolding.
So the next topic-- oh, right.
One more thing to show, this is
a very fun talk that we gave.
All five of us gave this
talk at Canadian Conference
on Computational Geometry.
And one of the props in the
talk was this cardboard box.
And in the middle of the
talk, it starts jiggling.
And actually, initially,
only four of the co-authors
were giving the talk,
because the fifth one
was hiding inside the box.
And then in the
middle of the talk,
he just jumps out
and then starts
speaking, as if
nothing happened.
It was a lot of fun.
At this point, our son,
Jonah, is in the box.
He was fairly small.
He's grown up a lot
since, but at the time
he fit nicely into
this cardboard
box, which was maybe this big.
I think we give him a
book and a flashlight
and stuff to do while he
was sitting there, waiting
for his slides, waiting
for the queue to come out.
There we go.
So those are unfolding of
the cube or a box in general.
Next topic is going
back to edge unfolding.
I like this comment.
I thought they were
pretty obvious,
but now you've
convinced me otherwise.
And some of the evidence for
edge unfolding being difficult
was this polyhedron, which we
proved has no edge unfolding.
I didn't say it in lecture, but
we call it edge on unfoldable,
because they cannot be unfolded.
This is actually the first
example we came up with.
I mention it only because
it has fewer faces.
We usually show this one
because it's triangulated
and that's kind of cooler.
This one has convex faces still,
so still topologically convex.
I mean, if I pushed
these points in,
the polyhedron would be
convex but has fewer faces.
It has I guess six faces per
hat, times 4 hats, so 24 faces.
This was done in '99.
It turns out at
exactly the same time,
there was this paper
by Tarasov called,
"Polyhedron with No
Natural Unfolding."
The paper has no figures,
so I had to draw one
to show you what it looks like.
It's just a cube.
And then at each corner of the
cube, you cut off the corner
and then pull the point out.
And they proved, by a pretty
similar argument-- I mean,
essentially you treat
each of these as a hat.
It's kind of a very simple hat.
They happen to overlap;
they share edges.
But again, because of these
negative curvature vertices,
you have to cut through the hat.
And that cut has to
keep going around.
Eventually, it forms a cycle.
So that's what Tarasov
proved in the same year, '99.
And then Grunbaum-- he's a
famous geometer in Seattle--
came up with some more examples.
So he initially wanted to
make a star shaped example.
Star shaped means that
there's a single point, namely
the center, where you can
shine a light in all directions
and the light reaches the entire
interior of the polyhedron.
He didn't know about
our witch hat example.
So he took the Tarasov example,
made it a dodecahedron,
and then it is star shaped.
I think ours are
already star shaped.
So that's kind of fun.
It looks like some scary
underwater creature.
And then he learned
about our paper,
and he said, all
right, I want to get
as few faces as possible.
And so we had 26, was it, 24?
This one has only 13 faces.
And it has tetrahedral--
well, that's not actually
tetrahedrally asymmetric,
because this bottom spike is
different from the others.
But it's kind of like
Tarasov's example down
to its very minimal
amounts, also star shaped.
And his conjecture is that,
if you have 12 faces or fewer,
there is no
un-unfoldable polyhedron.
So he says polyhedra with 12
faces are un-un-unfoldable.
He wanted to one up us.
Open problem is to define
un-un-un-unfoldable.
But we're up to three.
So that's some
un-unfoldable polyhedra
and some conjectured
un-un-unfoldable polyhedra.
This is fun to say.
The next result, which is
very recent is that-- this
is with Zach Abel
and myself-- that it
is NP-complete to decide,
given a polyhedron,
is it unfoldable or
un-unfoldable-- by cutting
along edges.
These are all
cutting along edges.
And we reduce from
this problem, which
comes from parallel
computers actually--
or geometry in general, you
want to pack a bunch of squares
into a square.
So you have squares
of different sizes.
And you want to pack those
squares into a given square.
Is it possible?
Yes or no?
Sometimes it is,
sometimes it isn't.
This proof, by many
people-- Long, et al.--
is from three partition,
which is a problem we've seen.
I won't go through it.
But essentially, it's kind
of like the disk packing
proof, which I showed in
lecture some time ago related
to tree maker.
But you set up this tiny
space and you end up
having to partition a bunch of
your squares into groups, each
with the same sum
groups of size 3.
So starting from this
problem of square packing,
how do we convert it into
an unfolding problem?
This is a rough idea
of the construction.
So the big picture--
this is initially
a polyhedron with boundary.
Later on, we'll
remove the boundary.
So just imagine a square, and
in the square, there's a tower.
Things are not
drawn to scale here.
The tower is super tall.
This little pipe thing is very
narrow and also very long.
I think even way longer than
anything in this picture.
OK, so now along the
side of the tower--
so this is an unfolding.
Like if you cut along these
edges, you get a plus sign.
This is the tower.
Now, this grid
stuff is something
that I haven't shown you yet.
But basically, think
of it as water.
It's very malleable.
It can be cut open in
many different ways.
And essentially, you don't have
to worry about it being there.
It's like the glue that
holds everything together.
But then, there's these
square faces, b1 up to bn.
These are the things
you need to pack.
So our goal is to set
things up that so, when
you take this tower out,
you have a square hole.
That is your target
square shape.
And then on the
side of the tower,
you've got all these squares.
Basically those squares
have to fit into that hole.
So it is square packing.
That is our goal.
Now, the challenge for that
is to make all of this stuff
get out of the way and
also for these squares--
normally when you unfold,
you're very constrained
in how you lay out the faces.
You can cut here or
cut here, but there's
a discrete set of choices.
Our goal is to design this stuff
so that these squares can just
basically move willy-nilly
without hitting each other.
It's not easy to do,
but that's the thing.
This is one big face on the
outside-- this kind of L shape.
We didn't want to go all the
way around for a couple reasons.
One is we need a place
for things to get out.
But also, we wanted this
to be topologically convex.
So we didn't want to
face that is a donut.
OK, so what's the next
part of the construction?
Well, if we can
arrange for these guys
to move willy-nilly-- that's
these very thin lines--
we can just imagine that
if the squares are somehow
packed, instead of having
things overlapping like this,
you can route all of those
paths to avoid crossings.
So as long as there's tiny gaps
between all the squares, which
doesn't turn out to change the
square packing problem very
much, you can do this.
And then there's another issue,
which is there's a lot of stuff
here.
You've got to put it
somewhere, so you end up--
it's very, very tiny--
so in some cases,
you have to do this
kind of wiggling just
to eat up length in
certain settings.
It gets complicated.
So how do we do
this wiggly stuff?
Well, at the first
level, there's
a very fine grid with
very small squares here.
And we set it up so that
we can follow everything
along a single path.
We can visit all of this great
stuff along a single path.
Occasionally, we will
encounter squares,
but the path length
between any two squares
is so big that these squares
have room to kind of stretch
out as far away from each
other as they need to go.
Now, these squares
are not squares.
They are actually
this construction,
which we call atoms.
It looks like a weird set of
pyramids, or outside of towers.
But in fact, there's many
different ways to unfold this.
There's lots of different
ways to cut it open.
And some of them go straight.
Some of them turn left.
Some of them turn right.
These are three of the
unfoldings, I forget.
There's a few dozen
unfoldings that we
need that all have
the right parameters.
This one's clearly turning left.
This one's going straight
in a certain sense.
This is coming from a left
turn and then going straight.
So there's lots of
combinations here,
slightly different
parities, and so on.
But the end effect is that if
you have a big grid of these
and you're following
them in a path,
the path does some
turns on the surface.
But you can force
it to do whatever
turns you want in the unfolding.
So you have complete freedom
to move the squares around.
As I showed you, you
can avoid crossings,
and it all works out.
Maybe one detail,
which I didn't mention,
is there's going to be
a ton of extra stuff.
Where does it go?
It's going to fill the pipe up.
It's going to push
these guys up somewhat.
And this thing is
so tall that there's
room to put all the
excess stuff in here.
And it's also so tall
that you can't just
reach all the way out and put
all the squares on the outside.
OK, so if you make that super,
super tall, none of the squares
fit in here, because
it's too narrow.
And none of the
squares can get up
to the top, because
it's too long.
So that's how it works.
Now, that was a
polyhedron with boundary.
Without boundary,
the construction
is almost the same.
You just add some extra
stuff on the outside
to make it a regular polyhedron
homeomorphic to a sphere.
But in the end, you have
basically the same construction
of this nice square.
The pipe and some other
stuff, you prove basically
doesn't matter.
So that is NP-completeness
of edge unfolding
of topologically
convex polyhedra,
even orthogonal
polyhedra, which is
kind of nifty-- from last year.
If you actually want
to unfold things--
if you want to build
things out of paper,
the current best heuristic
unfolder is called Pepakura.
It's a free download online,
probably Windows only.
You can take some
weird 3D model.
And it uses multiple pieces, in
general, but you can add tabs
and it's quite practical.
And cut it out, either
manually or with your computer
controlled sign
cutter or something
and then fold up your pieces.
When a one piece
unfolding is possible,
it will typically find it.
But it's not guaranteed.
I don't know exactly
what algorithm it uses.
But some combination
of brute force
and just cutting into
multiple pieces when it fails.
Next up, we have band unfolding.
So I talked very briefly
about band unfolding.
I thought I'd show you
some pictures about it.
And so remember, we're talking
about volcano unfoldings, which
is when you cut
along all the edges
from a point or it's sort
of in the vertical thing.
Band unfolding was when
you had some side faces,
you kept those intact and
cut everything else away.
So what do I have to show here?
This is an example of a band
unfolding gone wrong-- I guess.
It's a little hard to see.
This is, in general,
a prismatoid.
We had a top polygon, A,
here, and then below it,
this is polygon, B. We
took the convex hull, which
adds all these other edges.
And this is an example of a
bad unfolding of a primatoid.
Here's an example of
a bad-- this is really
a band unfolding
that has gone wrong.
So imagine here the top
polygon is this triangle.
Bottom polygon is this triangle.
That nicely nest.
It's a very easy
example, seemingly.
But for whatever reason,
we also added this cut.
And you can actually force
that if I make this not quite--
actually, maybe it's
not quite a triangle.
It's a quadrilateral.
Yeah, and this is
slightly a quadrilateral.
So when you take a convex
hull, you get that edge.
If you cut along that edge
and then cut along here
and cut along here and
do the band unfolding
thing-- we're not even drawing
the bottom polygon here-- just
the band itself overlaps,
which is annoying.
Nonetheless-- so this
is an old example--
but nonetheless, we proved
that there's at least one place
to cut the band--
like here would
work-- that will avoid overlap.
And this is some
parts the proof.
In general, here we're
looking at the inner polygon.
And we cut it somewhere.
And then we argue about where
that vertex goes if we open up
all the angles,
which is what happens
when you squash it flat.
And in particular,
we argue this vertex
must stay in the gray
region, like in the picture
on the right, so it
can't go up here.
And so in general, if you look
at how these things unfold,
if you're lucky, things will
be convex when you open it.
This is always going to be good.
There's this weakly
convex picture,
where when you
close the ends, it's
not quite convex but
only at one point.
This is troublesome--
sometimes this works,
sometimes it doesn't.
If you look at this
example, I believe
it is in the weakly
convex category.
I haven't told you the
other one is a spiral.
Here, if you draw a 90 degree
angle from this last bar,
then this guy is on wrong
side of that 90 degree thing.
This thing can't happen.
So that's comforting.
And it's related
to this property.
But these things
can cause problems
like in the previous picture.
And so you have to argue
that there is a place
to cut where you don't get
this or if when you get it,
it's still OK.
And that's a messy argument--
a lot of case analysis
I won't go through here.
I think I have one picture
of a nicely working example.
This is, I guess, a
general primatoid.
But here, we have a
nice cutting that works.
The original question that
someone here posed was,
what about prismoids?
So we know the band
unfolds nicely.
What we don't know is, can
you attach the top polygon
and the bottom polygons to
the band and get an unfolding.
We don't know, for example,
whether all prismatoids have
edge unfoldings,
because we don't
know how to place the
top and bottom things.
Probably possible
but really hard
to figure out where
they would go.
A simpler problem is prismoids--
which this might actually
be a prismoid.
If you know that
all of these edges
are parallel initially-- so it's
a very nice situation-- then
that's a more special
case from prismatoids--
then maybe you could attach
the interface and outerface.
We don't know.
We know volcano unfoldings
work for prismoids.
We don't know about
band unfoldings.
That could be an interesting
open problem to work on.
Maybe it's easy with prismoids.
They seem pretty clean,
but I don't know for sure.
Oh, another fun thing, which
relates to our next topic,
is that if you just
unfold the band part,
you can do it by continuous
blooming-- meaning there's
a continuous motion
from the folded thing
to the unfolded
thing, or vice versa.
And the easy way to see
that-- you kind of get
a sense from this picture--
in general, when you squash it
all the way flat, it opens.
Like this initial grey diagram
is a projection of the original
thing.
If you-- instead of
opening it all the way--
if you kind of squish
it from the top
and just keep lowering
that top face, at the end,
it's fully in the plane.
But in the middle,
you have a motion.
And by the same
argument, at all times,
you are non-self intersecting.
So that actually gives
you a continuous blooming
of the band of a prismatoid,
which is kind of cool.
So the next topic is blooming.
This is the last topic also.
A bunch of people asked
about continuous booming
and so the obvious one
to learn more about.
So I have some algorithms
and examples for you.
This is the paper--
a bunch of authors,
"Continuous Blooming
of Convex Polyhedra."
This problem was
posed by Connolly,
I believe, a bunch
of years prior.
It's still not known whether
every unfolding continuously
blooms.
It could be that
every unfolding--
every non-overlapping unfolding
of a convex polyhedron--
continuously blooms.
I would guess the answer is,
it doesn't but it's plausible.
That was the original question.
What we found are
two different ways
to continuously bloom
any convex polyhedron,
but we choose the unfolding.
So we have a couple
different strategies
for choosing unfoldings
that do continuously bloom.
Whether every unfolding
continuously blooms,
I don't know.
There are definitely unfoldings
of non-convex polyhedra that
do not continuously bloom,
based on knitting needles type
examples, based on
bad linkage stuff.
But for convex
polyhedra, I'm not sure.
So what do we have first?
First strategy actually starts
from any unfolding you have.
So we start here from the
cross unfolding of the cube.
And then it refines it.
So a similar strategy
to hinged dissection,
although I think this was
done before hinged dissection.
Let's take some
hinged structure,
add extra cuts and extra hinges.
In this case, I mean the hinges
are going to be the same.
It's just adding extra cuts.
So we're going to cut along
the red thing and also
this red dashed line.
The red thing is a
spanning tree of the--
or it's really the dual graph.
So we have, the
dual graph is you
have a vertex for every face.
You connect them together
if they share an edge.
In this case, when
they share an edge,
we're going to cut along there.
So we cut along
all this red stuff.
And the cool thing is, if you
walk around the red structure,
you get a cycle-- a
Hamiltonian cycle that
visits all the
faces exactly once.
We want to path, not a cycle,
so we add one more cut.
So then this blue
dash thing is a path.
And the claim is,
any path shaped
unfolding-- where the faces are
connected together in a path--
can be continuously bloomed.
How do you do it?
Roll.
So it's a little
easier for me to think
about unrolling
rather than rolling,
but they're the same thing.
So imagine, you
start with the cube.
And then you just roll it--
you unroll one face at a time.
So initially, there was a
90 degree fold angle here.
Just unroll it, so that now
they're in the same plane.
And there was initially
a 90 degree angle here.
Unroll that.
After three steps,
I think-- this guy's
been flattened, two, three--
we have this picture.
In general, I would
normally draw it rotated,
so that the unfolded part
lives in the floor of xy-plane.
And the polyhedron lives in z
greater than or equal to zero,
so lives above that plane.
What you know at all times
is that the unfolded part
is a subset of the unfolding.
It's a subset of this picture.
So it doesn't overlap itself.
If you start with a
non-overlapping unfolding,
you do this cutting.
And then you just take
some subset of the faces--
a prefix of the
path-- then that will
be a non-overlapping thing.
On the other hand, the
polyhedron that remains,
we haven't touched.
I mean, it's rotating.
You have to make sure it
stays above the plane here.
But it is just a subset
of the faces of the cube.
The cube is also not
self intersecting.
So any subset is not
So this thing doesn't
self intersect.
This thing doesn't
Potentially, this cube will
be resting on like f1 here.
It's possible for this thing
to unroll and just touch
the plane-- xy-plane.
But it won't penetrate it, just
because this thing's convex
and this is a plane.
So you can always keep this
thing above-- keep a convex
shape above-- or what
was a convex shape--
a partial version of a
convex shape-- above a plane.
But they can be
potentially touching,
even along two
dimensional surfaces.
So if you allow touching, this
is the path unroll algorithm.
It works fine.
If you don't want
to allow touching,
you need a slightly better
strategy, which I'll tell you.
It's pretty simple.
I won't argue that
it works, but it's
called the 2-step unfolding.
This is named after
the 2-step dance.
So we alternate between
two kinds of steps.
One is unfold of edge, ei, to
be almost coplanar-- sorry,
this should be a
face-- face, fi,
to be almost coplanar with
the previous one, fi minus 1.
So that does correspond
to unfolding an edge,
but I'm going to think
about numbering the faces.
Almost means we
unfold it to epsilon
within the angle of 180 degrees.
Then we finish unfolding the
previous step-- fi minus 1.
And then we repeat.
This is a little funny.
So we're worried that if
we unfold all the way flat,
we'll actually live in the plane
and then we'll touch things.
We don't want to do that.
So we're going to unfold
it almost all the way.
But when we're done,
we do want to be flat.
So I don't want to just unfold
everything almost all the way.
That might work, but
it's a little tricky--
the almost might interact.
So what I'm going to do is just
keep one guy almost unfolded.
That will be the previous one.
When I've almost
unfolded the next guy,
I will finish unfolding
the previous guy.
Then we will almost
unfold the next, next guy
and then finish unfolding
the next guy, and so on.
And this turns out to work.
Essentially, you've got
your fully planar part,
which is everything
before i minus 2.
That would be completely flat.
Then the next angle
will be almost flat.
And then the rest will
be in its original state.
And you can argue the
appropriate definitions
of almost.
There will be no--
in this case, there
will be no two
dimensional overlap.
You still can get an edge
resting on another thing--
still not quite perfect.
To make it completely
perfect, we need a waltz.
So the waltz is a
three step dance.
So the waltz, we have-- a
little tricky-- we unfold fi
to almost coplanar-- almost
180 degrees, with fi minus 1.
Then we unfold fi
plus 1 slightly.
And then we finish
unfolding fi minus 1.
So there's essentially
a potential interaction
between fi plus
1 and fi minus 1.
We do a little bit of
unfolding to prevent that
from being an issue here.
And so you end up with this
three step waltz thing.
Stefan Langerman is a dancer,
so he liked this terminology.
I won't argue here
that that works,
but now actually, you
avoid all touching.
Last picture I wanted
to show you is I
said there were
two ways to unfold.
One was you take any unfolding,
you make it Hamiltonian.
And then you unroll it, using
one of these three algorithms--
just regular unroll,
two step, or waltz.
But another strategy we know
works is the source unfolding.
Here, no extra cuts required.
Source unfolding is like the
cleanest, coolest unfolding.
It turns out it just unfolds.
No problem.
How do we unfold it?
We follow a post order
traversal of the tree of faces,
meaning we completely
do one subtree.
And now, here, we're in the
middle of doing this subtree.
So here, we just have a cube
with x being this point.
And so the reds are the cuts.
Pretty simple example.
You just have a
star of four prongs.
But here, we've completely
unfolded this subtree.
We've done one step
of this subtree.
The next thing we would
do is flip it open.
Then we do the next one,
then we do the next one.
Essentially what we argue
here, in one minute,
is as you unfold you
can think of-- well,
there's a couple
things going on.
One is just look
at a shortest path.
Right?
This source unfolding is made
by a star of shortest paths.
So just think of each shortest
path individually for now.
Individually, if you look
at a single shortest path,
it hits some sequence of faces.
Those faces form a
path-like unfolding.
So you just use path unroll.
And that will work.
The only issue is potential
interactions between the paths.
And that's where you have to get
into the post order traversal.
In general, you want this
shortest path to stay shortest.
What we're going to do
is imagine the polyhedron
in some sense as growing here.
So as we unfold-- like, as
we start unfolding this--
we can think of the
interior of the polyhedron
as just getting bigger.
And in that convex
polyhedron, it
turns out still these
paths remain shortest.
And by that, all the
variants to work out.
And you could argue
that the paths basically
don't interact with
each other, because
of post order traversal.
That was very hand wavy.
The actual proof is a
bit technical and more
than I can do in zero minutes.
That's a sketch of
continuous blooming
of source unfolding,
which is pretty cool.
Star unfolding is open.
Whether all unfoldings of
convex polyhedra work is open.
For non-convex
polyhedra, there are
bunch of non-convex polyhedra,
which we'll be talking about
in future lectures, that
we know have unfoldings.
Do they have
continuous blooming?
We have no idea.
This is the state of
the art for bloomings.
Still a lot of interesting
open questions.
Any other questions from you?
All right, that's it.